hello YouTube my name is Phil George i'm
professor Harvard Business School wrote
a book called true north and I am
passionate about leadership and I think
the most important thing we can do in
2008 is to select leaders who are more
committed to the global community than
the art of theirs personal self-interest
we need leaders not to collaborate
across country company and NGO lines and
bring people together in a collaborative
sense to to change the world and start
addressing the really tough problems we
have in the world by healthcare poverty
global peace education and until we do
that I don't think we're going to get
there until we get a new generation
leaders and so I'm really eager to see
the next generation leaders to overthrow
the baby boomers can step up to take on
leadership roles and start making this
world a better place right now